[Music]
good morning i hope you enjoyed
yesterday's temperatures because for
today we are going to be noticing a big
difference in the weather department
we're talking strong winds and the
chance of rain and mountain snow for
today's highs 80 degrees
those normal conditions should be of 77
degrees
no more record numbers like 92 said back
in 1937.
those lows will be a 45 degrees and we
are tracking
this low pressure system a cold front
pushing through this afternoon
this is what will give us all the
changes that we're talking about
the possibility to see some rain the
possibility to continue to track those
stronger wind gusts
as of yesterday it did mark day 187
without any measurable rainfall for
today we could potentially break that
those best chances for rain look to kick
in as early as five o'clock this evening
all the way into that
11 o'clock hour for the las vegas valley
we do have a 30
chance of rain all the way to 11 p.m
tonight
and after that those chances really
getting out of our way really pushing
towards the east
there could be the possibility of some
high elevation snow about 4 000
feet maybe a little bit of some dust of
snow
wind speeds though that looks to
increase as early as this afternoon
you're going to notice strong wind gusts
peaking
mainly for the evening you can see all
of that color representing the strong
dust and looking to come
our way up into the 30 to 50 miles per
hour the strongest once again for the
lakes
and for the colorado river valley all
the way into your monday
here's what you can expect in terms of
the peak gusts this evening
around six o'clock 21 miles per hour
before it increases to 25 the strongest
around 8 and 9 o'clock
this evening but we're also going to be
talking more about a freeze watch in
effect
late monday all the way into that
tuesday morning mainly for mesquite for
over 10 for
rump you could see those upper lows in
the 20s to
lower 30s make sure you protect your
pipes your pets
and your plants but for today we
continue to track the sunshine around
noon 78 degrees
the changes kick in in the evening
here's what you can expect in terms of
the conditions
80 degrees for today with a p.m rain
chance 58 degrees on monday
67 on tuesday before we increase back
again into those
70s and even warmer 70s for the
remainder of the week
the mountains forecast highs of 56
sprinkles chance
in the afternoon northwest winds staying
5 to 15 miles per hour and the lakes
highs of 83 with a slim
chance of rain tonight's lows 44 degrees
there is a 30 percent shower chance
north wind staying 15 to 20 miles per
hour
gusting all the way up to 30 miles per
hour here's your saturday day seven day
forecast we do have chances of rain for
tonight check out those conditions very
chilly out there you will need a sweater
before we increase back again
into those upper 70s those lows in the
50s have a great one